you
get ready maybe it'll be just as
exciting as last one maybe I'll lose a
game and just go on tilton lose some
more that should have happened actually
that one game where all I had was time
all right let's try Eve for the tennis
kid I was ready to go for Queen h5 stuff
Castle I'm gonna really go for that I'm
gonna push let's see what the knight
does he's probably not gonna move h5 no
he moved there you could take that night
out Knight f5 I'm gonna go here so I
have a knight here pawn push pawn put
yeah okay I'm gonna kick that night away
it's very weakening to my light squares
but I'm gonna I'm gonna shoot for it
let's go here I want to do this I did
not expect that I have a very weakened
King position and I go for this it's not
working oh yeah it is I have no it's not
really working
oh yeah it is I have to take here first
it's still not mmm
take here next I had to I had to really
think about the move order there and
then take here okay this is not um this
is not so great
obviously color Bishop's up it's a color
bishops and yeah it's it's just not so
great I'm gonna keep my Bishop right
there let's give a check King position
King position and I don't even know what
that does I guess that and then here
oh you can't jump your pieces it's not
checkers and so how do we move forward
here Wow
alright let's let's try this yeah this
is going to be very difficult to win
I'm gonna try something though mm-hmm
I'm gonna try something pushing through
like this all right and then come back
over I don't want where's my time I have
any time I lost I lost ah man back to
tournament negative - ah I was just
saying it would be cool if I like
chasing like if I lost it's um I could
maybe be trying to catch others from
behind but you definitely don't want to
lose the first game ah man
ah it really is painful okay I'm getting
a piece I could have taken the Queen
I should just resign take a freak weed
please take a free Queen the next time
she arrives on e4 and your night is on
f6 you need to do that it's important
it's important that you do that oh my
goodness this game should not be going
on still not even threatening anything
I'm in a pen yeah yeah that's a good way
to lose material let's not do that oh I
guess we'll do this I could have had the
Queen I could have still had the Queen
there all right give it up give it up
Knight takes pawn here after takes here
I guess we'll do this I'm stealing a pin
I am officially still in a pin oh man
let's get castled I do have a free piece
still am I missing any back rank stuff
Wow there was just a potential for the
adobe flash gambit what's that move
doing and take here back rancor well
close the rook has to drop back the
Queen's will be off the board I think I
think soon I think soon I'm gonna
actually be at zero points was wonderful
that's the that's the score you really
want to have I didn't have any good pre
moves in that game at the end I totally
didn't even see the
why am i dropping a rook why am I still
dropping a rock this is awful
that's me back to tournament zero 12 is
so long can I just stay afloat I'm maybe
maybe I should not have high
expectations with this one let's try to
just stay in the positive figures
shooting for those positive numbers
let's get out of negative the negative
zone alright maybe there could be some
sneakiness happening over here yeah the
night's gonna shot that one I shoot that
one right down yeah it's just not
happening I'm going for some fancy stuff
that just does not exist never a good
sign never okay I'm he was a stupid
piece anyhow and he - I'm glad to see
him go I could care less about that
bishop did I just was that insulting to
that Bishop or what all right let's
karate chop the Queen hit the bishop I
could take that with check let's get
over here mmm
I really don't want to do that oh that's
a nice move although there's Queen here
yeah okay I'm on the rook let's defend
this pawn my bishops unprotected I don't
need to castle I could have taken the
pawn let's pile away at it here pretty
much no matter what it's king in a run
crazy check let's do this and then this
I'm on here and oh oh my goodness how
many free pieces you're gonna miss
really I need to know that was the free
spaceship on e6 okay finally I did not
miss the free rook on d8 this is not a
good sign it really isn't
side back determined that's a good sign
I need quick resign errs 2012 I'm in
14th I'm really not showing up I'm
showing in the top 10 there it may
appear but really I'm 14th 14th is a
long way off from can
Fetty land efore I should have stopped
if Knight c3 you're supposed to play
Bishop to b4 okay you can take advantage
of that but maybe I could gain a tempo
against the Queen one day on the C file
close to maybe happening of a hanging
pawn structure this is a weak link on
III usually usually this Bishop will be
at first outside the pawn chain they
could grab that kind I guess gonna go
pawn hunting you really gonna do that
you're really going astray but maybe
it's okay dr. Seuss mode watch out for
that it happens from time to time I'm
weakening my dark squares but I want to
keep out Knight right here why am I not
doing something dangerous against the
king let's back up Knight takes here wow
that is super greedy that really is
super greeting I should be pushing this
Bishop around I should be throwing up
why am i dropping pieces Queen here I
got Knight here yes take somebody down
Bishop takes pawn might as well take
somebody out you're gonna lose him
anyhow okay Queen Trey and I grab here
27 seconds I have a clock advantage but
these are not quick wins not at all
get behind him he was doing nothing I
was a half open file mmm now I'm ready
to take and them promote otherwise there
was takes here with check where's the
bishop gonna go I take the knight I
guess we're gonna have one of these give
back some material they resigned back to
term in twenties thirties 30 2015 I got
10 22 minutes remain oh it's a big one
this is the leader come on start it up
why is there a delay there we go d4 Best
Buy tests gotta go fast this guy flies
alright we're gonna have something
simple let's see how simple turns out
alright Queen to b6 alright I'm in here
fast enough to get in b5
my nights gonna go for a little hike and
how do you defend this pond isn't that
difficult now hmm I jump in here I have
that a seven a six pun I have this
square covered two takes pawn takes it's
gonna be difficult to defend here yeah
let's do this move my bishops pin I need
to get castled yeah there's gonna be
something happening here I have this
move Knight takes pawn rook here this is
an annoying pin need to get out of it um
I guess I'm gonna do this I have to stir
some trouble up like this I guess let's
kick this night away if he moves then
there's Knight here to defend barely
that was super messy it still is messy
oh that was almost the adobe flash
gambit take here I guess push the pawn I
could take the pawn here not here next
it's way too complicated I got this
um I guess here and I take that night 11
sec I have a huge time edge right here I
guess sneaky stuff I have to
my rook it's very hard to do that I
shouldn't have tried
four time burners that was very
fortunate down
back to tournament I needed that but
that didn't that took forever
oh man that took forever it's a W but it
wasn't a clean W and not at all oh not
at all let's this is the no soup for you
move right there if you did not realize
no castling for you got it throw a
little Seinfeld reference in there every
now and then right let's back up my
queen remains a pest and she's gone just
like that do not blink I have a check
here I should be on the lookout for that
there's a hole on b6 can it be exploited
who knows who knows okay have a nice
Center let's stop Knight here okay dark
square issues my knight is going for a
hike hmm this is very scary very scary
take my bishop right here there might be
some tricky stuff happening soon my
knight wants to be a pest Oh is he a
pest and a half Oh deadly Ford that's
exactly what I needed
deadly forks get the rooks off otherwise
that would have been made whoo all right
let's get back over here and grab a
queen boom back to turn in 42 40 37 30s
28 I'm on the board their seventh plays
eighteen and a half minutes remain stay
tuned what's gonna happen I have no idea
let's try you for Bishop here and
alright let's grab a center kick the
knight around right now
maybe they're in pre-move mode defense I
should have done this dark square
weaknesses then let's let's go for it
right now I'm not going to take my
knight is going to be an animal right
here on e6 there's also this threat
Knight here would defend all right let's
grab some material otherwise I get the
Queen you have to give up the rook I
need to Castle Knight here could be
annoying let's stop the night here
queenside castle let's why didn't I move
why did I not move just then castle I'm
okay with giving up this bishop if
Knight here she has to do anything fast
let's just block that counterpunch can
test this file throw my knight in here
need quicker wins I'm up the exchange
less than 40 Bishop here is very active
the bishop could grab on b2 let's just
take him out let's take him here and
then Bishop to d4 more trades is what I
want
Queen c5 I could break the pin and
defend my rook okay this is a very
active post for my Queen Queen to f6 I
just defend this is a bishop here bishop
take c2 look here look here no matter
what and let's kick the King away he
gets to go in reverse there that was a
good move to keep the King out
I should be grabbing on this square if
King here I'm just gonna drop back to f2
just to make sure I don't lose this guy
could be throwing in this check um that
wasn't the greatest was it they're gonna
be sneaky with their pawn move I want to
make sure I get rid of this guy alright
that's check I'm on the bishop just take
him out connected past pawns
okay just run with this guy he's fast
he's past and they're down on time 56 54
42 42 40 we're not even halfway there
still a lot of time to recover if you
lose that first game okay 16 minutes 20
seconds is this guy gonna move yes maybe
a little bit of a connection issue
mm-hmm all right let's build a center
I'm not so sure the Queen really belongs
on c7 pawn push I'm not committed to
castling kingside just yet I'm gonna
keep him around maybe and do some
weaknesses here sorry about that night
to g3 I want to support my knight
maybe I'll get the g5 takes know I'm
certainly much more inclined to go Queen
side Queen side and throw pieces over
here on the G file they should be trying
to come at me on this side of the board
but I should be able to defend here okay
let's stop this maybe just develop my
bishop just yet I don't know if I want
to commit my King just yet what about
Knight here to b3 King is on the same
dog and I was my queen there might be
some tactics there I'm looking to get
here
I think I could get that in whoa I'm not
going to take with the bishop or queen
I'm just gonna drop back with my knight
pawn push I play here and then I want to
just secure my knight position this is a
very strong post and you know what I
could do now
I could castle I'm gonna maintain my
bishop here or at least hope to do just
that
no he's gonna be removed let's get my
king here let's free up my bishop can't
even get on this diagonal why have I not
yet played let's go here why have I not
yet played a piece over here on g2 I
don't have a good answer to that I
really don't let's get here and then
finally double and then generate a
threat how long is it going to take
before you do that back determine
they're down on time I don't even throw
a significant punch at my opponent there
it was strictly positional okay how we
doing 54 I'm in fifth place fifth place
what's that Queen up to no idea there's
a little bit of lag there they're trying
something over here we don't and throw
my knight in to d5 Bishop there I'm
still gonna take let's kick him away get
out of this pin I'm gonna take here and
then here take the bishop and I really
am gonna take this guy right here I
could get away with it I could get away
with a different story if this pawn is
on f5 ooh which is close to happening
okay that Queens gonna sneak over okay
let's grab here finally I would I would
have had something like King g2 rook h1
stuff I'm on f7 right now very difficult
to defend and actually close to me in a
few I guess here with check Knight could
block I could take the knight and then
get my other rook to f1 that's check
this is check and then mate next on e7 I
think we have a quick win we do the
Queen must block and this is maintenance
back to tournament 70 90 88 72 72 70 13
minutes remain still a lot of time I
need to still keep winning though all
right
let's still go with this maybe I'll be
successful I think this is one of the
first times I'm playing this guy let's
get this pawn involved maybe he'll do
something good
I'll put pressure on h3 soon Queen here
okay let's drop back not the best move
ever but okay let's get my bishop
working okay let's take care I want to
remove their light square bishop I know
you're gonna get shot down pawn push
that was silly okay no quick kills this
pawn is probably gonna get hit soon yep
Knight here let's maybe get this move in
I need to get some break over here no my
Knights running in to do or my Queens
running into some trouble Knight tempo
moves yeah I was ready to just drop my
queen Knight here I got to play e5 let's
go with the e5 make some break in the
center and okay mmm this game is not
ending anytime soon I gave up the
LightSquared Bishop Knight here is gonna
be very appealing I don't have my dark
square Bishop and oh I'm in trouble
Queen check here yes very painful
definitely very painful you take here I
get a fork would they really do that
night here mmm oh there's another fork
here this is a disaster oh my goodness
this is awful I'm down on time
and everything and I can't save this can
i no way 11 seconds and yeah
not happening hmm yeah they're gonna
have a ton of time one point I can't
even move oh that's painful
that's the tournament ah man you see
what happened as soon as I drop my what
wasn't as soon as my dark square Bishop
left the scene man my king was so much
more vulnerable I got to do something
other than this positional stuff
definitely definitely have to try
something crazy town and this is not
crazy town I got a launch
I got a launch H ponds and stuff there's
no way you could come back from this is
there I don't see it I don't see way
that you could really come back unless
h6 is played
unless h6 is played let's try that and
running tonight to be far though I am on
h7 no I just dropped my bishop oh my
goodness this is gonna hurt though I
could take on g6 mmm this is still
interesting night here though well I
don't know about that
okay the King's gonna run for his life I
guess
Queen here I'm looking for me and one
that's gonna be seen what about that
though isn't that scary it's got to be a
little bit scary just a little bit
there's something happening here some an
accident is gonna happen let's try this
you can take my bishop double-check
that's a double check and a half okay
it's close to maybe happening
hit the Queen again let's hit the knight
Knight here is now gonna happen let's
hit him what about this my bishop could
be taken now although no there's night
there all right where's the sneakiness
now sneakiness really just a clock
advantage chase this night away and then
land this and then go here it's not
really going to matter clock
disadvantage big time I could have taken
the rook
they're just moving like crazy and so my
time burners okay back to chairman 148
can I get in confetti land 86 I'm not
even hit a third digit nine minutes
remain
okay how can I do cheap tricks here
let's try this you know that was really
exciting here okay
lining something up I guess okay we're
gonna Castle queenside no we're not I
don't know we're gonna do let's plant a
night here and secure them with that
five all right let's try this there we
go that's the idea that's the ticket
if the Night Moves who I have something
good brewing here that's gonna be me yes
I needed that I definitely this is matin
next move unless that move is played
okay I gotta go here it's still gonna be
me how does fast as I thought though
Bishop here Queen here is the only way
to delay it
Queen age one mate if I gave check too
soon King f2 he runs away for real fast
32 seconds they want to drive they
really mean to hit the the resign button
are they gonna let the clock tick don't
do that okay there we go that's me back
to tournament 106 150 150 148 130 that
was fairly quick I need to get another
one in I could still get a few more
games and maybe four games d4 I'm doing
this no matter what I don't care
gambit mode d5 that still here anything
take oh my goodness okay this this is
maybe not a bad idea not a bad idea we
have a lot of central dent essential
tension the center could be liquidated
very quickly Queen takes here I'm taking
on b7 let's scare that night away and
maybe take here oh now let's let's not
do that just yet I need to defend this
pawn let's go over here check Queen here
Bishop here this could be very nice
okay pawn
oops oops oops punished a block and
let's come back here I want to get rid
of one of the Knights throw a rook to d1
in there all right Knight here mmm
okay this was not so great
they got castled there the knight could
still play there okay they're in a pin
it's got to be a very uncomfortable pin
Bishop takes or just Bishop here how do
they defend that the knight has to
defend it it's not working out so I'm up
a piece right here trade I already have
a flight square trade some more take
right here and drop my queen back here
most likely no matter what unless my
bishop is attacked all right and
probably here unless there's a crazy
rook to d3 now let's be more aggressive
let's do this and exploit this pin right
now I have this diagonal covered with
that F pawn push I could be pointing at
FS okay they forfeit on time that was
fairly quick 170 170 170 126 Wow six
minutes remain that second last was one
too many honey alright it's well aware
of these uh sneaky tricks here we're
gonna have d5 pushing all right so
that's not gonna happen no fast wins
here take my knight yes it's official
he's gone and okay let's do this
and put pressure on d5 soon c4 there's
not an ensuing d5 move let's get my
bishop here maybe something on the G
file Bishop here stuff okay I was
probably gonna go there no matter what
it feels like it's close to main yeah if
the rook moves there this is matin to
Knight block and I take here in its main
that's main back to tournament 21 91 91
91 66 146 so far off can i maybe get a
oh the bird the bird is the word I was
gonna say maybe can I give fourth place
there's no confetti there though that's
where it's at you want to get the
confetti stuff all right I don't even
know what this is doing okay and all
right I'm gonna take my night what am I
doing this is ridiculous
night here I guess my queen could so
easily be kicked from the defense of
this pond it seems very crazy but this
push is probably quite good I need to
eliminate this night so let's get him
out of there in fact he's won I got this
g5 Square covered g5 I just dropped back
to well I don't have very many choices
hmm my queen trap no okay yeah that's
fine g4 I come back to f4 the night is
still attacked
I guess best is maybe take here allow
this capture and then they have a really
strong pawn mass it's a good decision
right there a good decision right there
I'm looking to pick up maybe a full rook
with this but it's still tricky still
very tricky here let's take here and
then take here with check and then this
is falling on f5 and then here I could
officially trade Queens if I wanted to
let's maybe see if I could get a mate
the Queen somewhere I want to keep the
Queens on pawn push
keep pushing my pond and then Queen f7
they resigned back determine 232 10 to
10 mm it's so far off 325 325 can i
maybe get fourth place we're gonna see
we're gonna see about that okay ecigs
take I'm gonna keep the Queen's on try
it again
still Castle okay still gonna go for it
he is a super annoying piece on that
square he really is I don't even know
what that does I don't care about my
night I have control oh this is this is
the win of the Queen whoa okay that was
the win of a queen here I could have
taken the rook I'm gonna do that soon
here here trade light square bishop and
then get in on h2 mate next are close to
mate that's one to quickly back to
tournament one 186 - 30 - 10 - 10 1 good
night can I catch that guy if I'm two
minutes two minutes remaining
main line caro-kann space advantage with
tempo I should have done this ah
ok whoa is he a giant thorn and a half
on that east six square
he could be defended though I know he
could be removed no now I got Bishop
here maybe Queen to d6
maybe that was a mouse slip this Queen
is close to trapped Bishop here I'm
looking for mate I'm looking for mate
with this is a help mate
that's mate back to term in 206 - 32 32
32 Oh 6 I still need to wins I can only
get 20 points one of those guys is
clearly gonna win can I get a quick
resigner
and then another win whoa this guy's
going crazy town
let's check Queen here next if pawn push
bishop
if Knight blocks I don't want a Queen
trade not in this position here our
bishop here next I don't want a queen
trade Bishop here I need to end these
games quicker Bishop here
um ah I gotta go for Queen trade can I
manage it maybe with bishops can the
bishops deliver mate somehow quickly
yeah it's not happening 47 seconds
remain I guess I just have to try to win
one game this one here the rook mm-hmm
that's a check here get this in take
here the Knights gonna block that's a
pin keep him in a pin the King might run
to f2 I'm gonna give a check with the
other piece 27 seconds 20 on the they
resigned back determine 250 250 250 250
270 whoa okay there's only 10 seconds
remaining I gotta try a scholars main
scholars may alert is this guy gonna
move oh there might be a 15 he resigned
oh I just got a boos fourth place 4th
place are they calling it it's completed
4th
I'll take fourth 2/4 oh we retired last
time too I guess I want untie breaks
right there oh man oh my goodness look
at these top three guys they had a
fantastic tournament 18 out of 18 17 out
of 17 for both 2nd and 3rd nice Jack
Jack's Hester ultra dread and mr. cute
fanatic very nice a fourth pop height is
a fifth and I was between us well really
between those guys I was only ever I was
only I was always two games out from
even thinking about confetti land all
right
good games
oh very nice
official oh it's close to being a main
intuitive ins Bishop here that's a check
no it's not I dropped my queen I dropped
my bishop I thought that was a check Oh
No